متابعينا الكرام النتائج الاوليه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه تشير الى فوز
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان بولايه جديده
وخساره مرشح تحالف المعارضه كمال كلجدار
اوغلو وذلك وفق النتائج الاوليه غير
الرسميه
في هذه الجوله جرت عمليات الفرز بسرعه
اكبر من الجوله الاولى نظرا لوجود
متنافسين اثنين فقط وكذلك لان الجوله
الاولى كانت تتضمن انتخابات عامه لاختيار
اعضاء البرلمان ومن المفارقات في هذه
الجوله ايضا انضمام 47 الف شاب الى قوائم
الناخبين بعد اتمامهم السنه القانونيه
للاقتراع في فتره اسبوعين فقط ما بين
الجوله الاولى والجوله الثانيه وللتذكير
فان صناديق الاقتراع اغلقت ابوابها عند
الساعه الخامسه بالتوقيت المحلي هنا في
تركيا واثناء ادلائه بصوته في اسطنبول قال
الرئيس اردوغان ان تركيا اكدت ماده تمسكها
بالديمقراطيه وان الشعب سيختاروا رئيسه
[موسيقى]
الناتج بدوره ناشد منافسه كماله الجدار
اوغلو الاتراك بالتوجه الى صناديق
الاقتراع والدفاعي عن اصواتهم في هذه
الانتخابات التي تجري في ظروف صعبه حسب
قولهم
وجديد بالذكر ان نتائج الجوله الاولى
اسفرت عن حصول اردوغان على 49 ونصف في
المئه من الاصوات في حين حصل منافسه كمالك
لجدار اوغلو على
44.8 في المئه اذا انتهت عمليات الفرز
والجميع يتراقب الاعلان الرسمي للمجلس
الاعلى للانتخابات
[موسيقى]